好,今天分享三個操作手法
把上一次影片還沒講完的部分講完
上一次我們講到是怎麼樣
在前一天買到158,然後第二天決定賣在169
那這單成功賺了54萬
然後我們今天來講下半場我們是怎麼樣
成功的在142.5的跌停價買回
我們的這個大約30口長榮旗
然後講一下在中場的時候
三種我認為可行的不同選擇
那當天
呃前面發生的事情你們可以去看
這個上一支影片
就有說明
然後後來是
這個延後開盤然後一個暴跌
然後後來就一路跌
那我現在要講的是在10點多這個10點整左右的時候
可以做的三個選擇
那當時的20日線
是
大概在150
然後也算是一個整數關卡
所以
150算是一個支撐
那
這個我先講
最不好的選擇
就是
因為150是支撐
所以在150
直接
掛多單
在150買進
為什麼不要直接在支撐掛買單
這個
我也是
上個影片有
這個講
就是因為
剛好
就是我想說拍這個影片然後
中間會有很多的概念
但是這樣影片會變很長
所以我就把它分成好幾個影片來拍
然後
好就是因為
如果你在
掛在支撐買進的理由是
你覺得
從169跌到150
都已經跌快20塊了
那都跌20塊了
跌很多
你看他不爽
所以打多單
這個是
最不好的理由
那當然相反過來也是一樣
比如說防疫股
這個一直狂漲
漲了快要100%
然後你看他不爽
所以你去空他
就是
這種
因為他已經漲很多
所以你空他
或因為已經跌很多
所以你打多單
都是最不好的理由
因為這樣你打進去的單
都是逆勢單
所以
就是我
上個影片講的
你應該在
趨勢
開始改變
之後進場
這個是最
這個
標準的做法
好
然後
這個
這個線型也可以稍微記起來
就是在
一個大跌跌到一段支撐之後
如果
跌破這個支撐
如果是一個大跌
之後盤整
然後跌破支撐
那
後面
會
很容易在往下跌很長的一段行情
原因是因為在
這個支撐這邊多空交戰
的多單
會
全部停損
那同時停損就會變成
往下貫的行情
然後
如果
相反的方向也是完全一樣的意思
如果在
上漲很大一段之後
在一個
壓力
多空交戰
那突破壓力的時候
突破壓力打多單也會很好
因為
會
往上再噴很大一段
空單會一起停損
好所以在
10點之後的第一個選擇
就是我認為最
正派或是說最標準的選擇就是
如果在
150的支撐被
暴大量
袋量跌破的時候打空單
這個我們看一下
在
大概在這邊的時候有這樣的情況
支撐不會是單一一個數字
會是一個範圍
例如說
150的附近都是一個支撐帶
152到148這個附近
那也不一定會打到支撐
就是
快要到支撐的時候那個地方就有多空交戰
然後在
這一根5分K的時候
這個是
12000多張
然後被帶量跌破了這個支撐
跌到了
7.5
那大概在這個地方的時候
這個
追空打空單
會不錯
因為我剛剛說那個線型
跌了一大段之後整理
再跌破
支撐
這個地方打空單
那我認為是一個好的選擇
那當然停損就是
這個又
漲回
漲破支撐
例如說
這個抓1.5%
這個回到150停損
那第二個選擇就是
這個是
右邊交易的做法在
這個趨勢改變之後進場
那另外一個
做法是左邊交易的做法
就是
因為
當天的
這個特大單差已經到
負20%以上
也就是說當天的
這個
大人主力的
動向是非常非常空的
然後當天的成交量
預估量
量比
已經到了
接近
10萬
那前一天是
前一天是
29萬多
這樣子
所以是
接近兩倍
所以它的量比是非常大的
是爆量
然後很可能是一個趨勢盤
而且一直下跌
所以
在150
附近
當天要
V上來的機率
這個是非常非常低的
那
比較有可能的是
跌破支撐
下去
或者是
就在150附近盤整
到收盤
前一天也比較接近這樣的情況
然後
所以
其中
第二個
在
這個
支撐附近的選擇就是
左邊進場的做法
就是在
爆大量多單進場
之後
你觀察它的這個
進單速度
多單大概停止了
比如說到152.5附近
或是152的這個地方
你打空單
因為你認為
這個多單的反擊
會力竭
然後例如說
在這個地方
這個5000張多單進場
152的時候
你打空單
那
這樣就是在這個
空方趨勢行程前
你就打空單
那我自己是
比較少用這樣的做法
就是
也比較
不符合我
平常交易的方式
不過
也是跟大家分享
有人穩定用這種
這個
左邊進場的方式
是在獲利的
就是在
爆大量的多單
力竭的時候
打空單
這個是
第二個我認為
我自己的做法
那我自己當天的做法是
第三種做法
就是
也是因為剛說的那個線型
如果支撐被跌破
則很有可能直接衝到
142.5的跌停
那
這個在我的
這個課程裡面有講到有些情況下的
跌停股票是
買了
這個超底是
獲利的機率是非常非常高的
那當天就是這樣的情況
就是可以把它做成隔日蟲
如果我當天能買到跌停的
142.5
那第二天
非常高機率我可以
開高出道
那
實際上
第2天
也是
這個開盤的時候有到
147.5
就是到148啦
可以出到147.5
這是第1跟
這個5分K的時候
所以
當時
我買到是長期次月
為什麼買次月
因為那天是結算日
這個也是看上個影片
大家可以學習到
好
然後
就是這樣
所以我在10點的這一根
我是在10:03的時候
就已經掛了跌停的長期次月
然後我就帶我的狗出去跑步
就出去玩
因為早上這單
我已經賺50幾萬了
所以後來
我就覺得反正我就用最簡單不用看盤的方法就是第3個選擇
就是掛跌停然後就出去玩了
那如果看盤的話
就是
前兩個選擇
是
可能我當天會做的
不過因為有可能他就會一直在支撐一直盤整到收盤
這個
也不一定會能夠成功有單可以進
好所以
當天我的選擇就是
這個
比我10點03分晚掛單的
跌停價
長期的長期次月我就全爆了
就是
當天確實
我買了28口回來
然後
這個比我玩掛單的人是完全買不到的
因為全部
全部都被我買走
然後
所以總結起來
我在
這個
169賣的是158的前一天隔日充
這邊是賺50幾萬
然後後面
這個
142.5賣到
147.5
開盤的時候
我是
這個
賬面上是
賺30萬
左右
所以
這一天的操作
這個
賬面上我是賺
80幾萬
然後
如果我今天
這天沒有操作的話
就是例如這天我在
睡覺或者是
我不知道反正就如果沒有做的話從158到
147.5的話我大概會虧
60萬吧
所以我才寫說來回是
這個150萬就是
如果我不操作
今天的這個169賣
142.5買回的話
會虧60萬然後實戰我是賺
這一天是賺80幾萬
好
那
大家有什麼問題
或是有什麼想聽的可以
再跟我說
就是
跟大家講一下
這一天的幾個操作手法
然後還有
不要直接在支撐處
接多單買
大概是這樣吧
好
掰掰